it will in short the the development of
a new fourth television network serving
all the peoples of the 50 states that
are this land if the federal government
were to cut off funding for public
broadcasting the programs that so many
of us are cooperative not only wouldn't
disappear the secret government has no
constants they would have a better
chance of surviving long into the future
[Music]
he had proposed that the airwaves belong
to the people a proposal that now
becomes law with President Johnson's
signature on the public broadcasting Act
in 1967 President Johnson established a
system of government subsidies for
public broadcasting that hasn't changed
much in 50 years the lion's share of
federal money was allocated not to pay
directly for programming but to go to
independent public television and radio
stations that were established in every
corner of a vast nation their main
purpose has always been to distribute
national content to their local
communities 50 years ago maintaining a
network of regional station was the only
way to ensure that every household had
access to public television and radio
content distribution of the preceding
program was the service of the 1967
about 70% of government funding went
directly to the local stations 50 years
later that formula hasn't changed
today they are 1,400 public radio and
television stations supported by the
federal government this method of
distributing content hasn't only
outlived its purpose the regional
stations have become an obstacle now
that audiences have started watching and
listening to public media in completely
new ways
good evening I'm Judy Woodruff that I'm
I'll the run the internet means that
consumers can now access PBS and NPR
content anywhere in the world and on
their own schedule aware yet and as
audiences move online the regional
stations kept alive by the federal
government simply aren't necessary
anymore but it's not just that they're a
waste of money
the local stations are also making it
harder for PBS and NPR to fully embrace
the Internet
anyone without much capital investment
can make a podcast put it on a server
and get a worldwide audience for this
the advent of podcasting which was a
singular opportunity for NPR to
capitalize big and a new way of
distributing its rich content thanks for
listening to the NPR politics podcast
today and he our publishers many of the
top podcasts but in the interest of
self-preservation the regional stations
have also created obstacles for example
NPR show hosts are forbidden from
promoting podcasts on the radio or from
even mentioning NPR's popular smartphone
app station opposition is also the
reason that podcast listeners can't
download episodes of NPR's two top
programs recently some of Public Radio's
most talented show hosts and producers
have been leaving to go work for private
podcasting ventures one reason to lead
says NPR defector Adam Davidson is that
podcasters have a creative freedom that
NPR's institutional friction simply
can't allow the fact is that without
federal subsidies the program's
themselves would be more likely to
thrive about 40 percent of funding for
public broadcasting comes from private
contributions for public radio it's
about 60% without the massive overhead
cost of 1,400 local public radio and
television stations that revenue would
more than cover the costs of producing
the program and then distributing them
for free online and yet fans of PBS and
NPR might ultimately be better served if
they were to privatize and charge a
monthly subscription fee moving in the
same direction as the rest of the media
either way ending federal funding not
only won't destroy the only thing that's
worth saving about public broadcasting
it could very well be its salvation
[Music]
you